I get a deep sense of hope
when I look at this brick.
(Laughter)
It's going to spend
the next 50 years of its life
cutting CO2,
and bricks like it are going to cut
15 percent of world CO2.
So let's talk about that,
but first, we have to talk about fire.
Fire warms us, heats our homes,
cooks our food.
We also use fire
to make almost everything.
Industrial production, making stuff,
uses more fossil fuel than any other part
of the world economy.
We burn coal, oil and gas
to make steel, calcined cement,
cook baby food, make glass, make fabric,
everything.
We don't notice it in our daily lives,
but industrial energy use is the largest
part of the total world economy,
and industrial heat
is a quarter of world fossil-fuel use
and world carbon emissions.
Let me say that again --
industrial heat is a quarter
of world carbon pollution.
We need the stuff we make.
We need to decarbonize our industry,
not deindustrialize.
How?
If we had a new kind of fire,
we could decarbonize today
and avoid the time and costs
associated with replacing
our factories that run on heat.
If we had clean heat ...
we could have the stuff that we use
and we could have a giant drop
in world emissions.
But for decades,
we've dreamed of burning hydrogen
or capturing carbon to get clean heat,
but costs and challenges
continue to delay their deployment.
The good news is today, there is a faster,
cheaper way of doing it --
electrification.
Analysts now say
that electrified industrial heat
is the next trillion-dollar market.
I agree, they're right,
because the ongoing cost-dropping
in wind and solar --
power costs now are dropping
to the point that wind and solar cost less
than the fuels our factories burn.
So we have the economic conditions
to drive to scale.
We also have the capacity
to build at scale.
Today, we have everything we need
to build wind and solar at scale
to repower industrial heat.
Yes, it's terawatts,
it's five times more wind and solar
than is in the world today.
But there is a solution.
We have everything we need,
except continuity.
Right? The wind blows and the sun shines
only some of the time.
Heavy industry needs heat all the time.
So we need to store energy
some of the time
so we can have clean heat all the time.
How?
Most ways of storing electricity
are too expensive or inefficient
to use for industrial heat.
But what if we just stored heat?
Storing electricity as heat
can be simple and really low-cost.
Teams around the world
are now trying to build
industrial heat batteries
that store energy this way,
using new materials, like liquid salts,
liquid metals and solid carbon.
And some of these are going to work.
They'll take time,
time to learn if they're safe,
time to learn how long they last,
time to learn how to make
a lot of something new.
My colleagues at Rondo
found a way to save time,
to go faster,
by using old materials
that the world already makes in volume.
What were they?
Here's a hint -- one of them was brick.
The other was iron wire.
Why brick?
200 years ago, the steel industry
introduced a coal-saving technology.
They started building blast stoves
that store heat at thousands of degrees
in thousands of tons of brick.
Brick is basically made from dirt,
and dirt is available at scale.
(Laughter)
When it's red-hot,
a brick stores as much energy
as a lithium-ion battery, per pound,
costs ten times less,
lasts ten times longer.
Half a million tons of brick
are storing heat at steel mills
around the world, right now.
Iron wire?
A hundred years ago,
a new alloy for heating elements,
from toasters to industrial furnaces,
was invented.
It is made only of iron
with a little chromium and aluminum.
Today, that heating element
is on your kitchen counter
and in industrial furnaces and kilns
around the world.
Combining brick and wire
could be really cost-effective.
We would know how to make
a lot of it right away,
but there are some challenges.
If you overheat a brick on one side,
if you don't heat it evenly,
it can crack.
If you overheat just one spot
on a wire, the wire may fail.
We've finally found the way to do it.
The way to combine these
was to heat brick the way
your toaster heats bread,
the way the sun heats the Earth
with radiant heat.
It only took us 74 design revisions
to find the solution,
and hundreds of simulations.
But the key insight --
heating brick with radiation.
We built a 3D checkerboard
of brick and open chambers.
The chambers let radiant heat
spread the heat evenly
so electricity can heat
thousands of tons of brick
to thousands of degrees,
safely and evenly.
Once you've done that,
now you have stored energy,
and delivering clean heat
is really simple:
push air into the brick stacks,
superheated air comes out
that powers your kiln or your furnace,
or heats a boiler to make steam
for your chemical plant
or your food-production facility.
Presto, you have a heat battery:
an industrial boiler
that runs all day, all night, all year
on the wind or the sun.
A cement kiln that burns no fuel,
a chocolate factory with zero scope 1
and scope 2 emissions.
Simple, low-cost and efficient.
I brought this brick for show-and-tell.
It's going to spend
the next 50 years of its life
in a heat battery,
running at thousands of degrees,
over a thousand C.
When it's at temperature,
it stores more energy
than a Tesla Model X.
We put about 3,000 of those in a box
to make one heat battery.
(Laughs)
We didn't have spares,
this is actually going into a unit.
(Laughter)
We are now at this very interesting point.
Technology like this is simple.
It's boring. It can go to scale fast.
If you want to go to scale fast,
it's good to be boring,
to use these simple processes.
There is a valley of death
that everyone talks about,
about new technologies,
between new technologies
where high capital costs
can absorb uncertainty,
and low capital costs,
huge infrastructure,
needs certainty.
New and boring
is a really strange combination,
but it's an excellent recipe
for going fast.
Leading climate-investment funds,
industrial producers
agreed that our kind of boring
is a good idea,
and have helped us build a great team
to build big and go fast.
Today, Rondo is supplying heat
for low-carbon fuel production
and developing projects around the world
that will produce food,
chemicals, metals and cement.
We are producing bricks at gigawatt scale
and growing that production,
over the next few years, a hundredfold.
So we're at the beginning
of a rapid ramp.
Tackling our climate crisis
needs our will,
but it also needs tools to build big,
new energy infrastructure fast.
This is one of those tools.
It's a six-gigaton tool.
Analysts say the fully decarbonized world
needs twice as much heat-battery storage
as grid-battery storage.
Heat batteries powered by the wind and sun
will lower, not raise, the cost
of making the things we need
in the decarbonized world.
This new kind of fire
will power a safer, more prosperous,
more just world for our children
and their children.
Our challenge, Rondo's great opportunity,
is to build at scale
to repower the world's industries,
and save 15 percent
of world CO2 emissions.
And with your help,
we can get that done in 15 years.
That's why I have hope,
and I hope you do, too.
(Applause)
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)